major left-wing double standard when it
comes to overheated rhetoric now that
maxine waters words will be used against
democrats during the impeachment trial
this week
the congresswoman is denying she was
encouraging violence against members of
the trump administration
when she said comments like this if you
see anybody
from that cabinet in a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
you get out and you create a crowd
[Applause]
can you say that you have not glorified
or encouraged violence against
republicans
absolutely i can say it as a matter of
fact if you look at the words that i use
the strongest thing i said was tell them
they're not welcome
talk to them tell them they're not
welcome i didn't say
go and fight i didn't say anybody was
going to have any violence
plus more yawns from democrats and the
media after antifa members threatened to
burn down dc
during a black lives matter march
recently
so greg the fact checkers are now
coming to maxine waters defense and
saying that she never said
what she said yeah and also it's not but
it's not just her
it's an accumulation of threats and
intimidations
followed by inaction of the media and
inaction of the politicians that
contributed to
what i would call the extortion of
violence if trump
won in 2020 there will be blood
hence you had the boarded up buildings
all over the cities
in new york uh uh la whatever people who
were fearful of abide in loss
not a trump loss were boarding up their
buildings so that what that what does
that tell you
that there was a side more inclined to
violence the problem here is if you
demonize people long enough
other people will act on it the warfare
won't stop until both sides police
their own sides so the democrats have to
take violence from antifa
and blm as seriously as the republicans
did
for the capital right see the it's easy
for republicans right because
they come out of the womb pro-law
enforcement
so they're like they find everything
that violates the law
left or right to be offensive right and
including a one-off at the capitol that
has like never happened
among like trumpers right so but
remember what we're learning here is
that only the left can call for
revolution only the left can overthrow
and demonize and only the left can
riot loot and destroy and that's because
they have the implicit backup of the
media
because they all believe that the
personal is political if your heart's in
the right place
you're not evil how did communism kill
100 million people
because their heart was in the right
place and they had people in the media
people americans defending them in the
name of equality
and they do reach equality in the terms
of equally
all dead you know jesse the one big
problem with this issue of hypocrisy on
violence you know condoning one kind of
violence we're refusing to condemn the
other
is that it's about standards it's about
fairness and it's about treating these
things
equally and we're not seeing that at all
when it comes to the media
and democrats who are now impeaching
president trump when
you could argue maxine waters should
also be impeached for the things that
she has said
exactly maxine waters no relation if you
put her words in trump's
mouth on january 6th we would have that
speech memorized and take a look at the
full context she actually says
god is on my side we will win this
battle
we will kick trump in the rear and stomp
him out
and then she says get in their face and
push back later she says
absolutely harass trump supporters so by
their own logic
you could make all the democrats
accessories to all the crimes
that they've committed against trump
supporters and those crimes
that is a long list breitbart has a rap
sheet
on all the crimes against trump
supporters i i ran out of paper
printing it out katie republican office
is
fire bombed shot at and vandalized
republican politicians
shot attacks with switchblades assaulted
you've seen them chased all over the
place
we've had regular trump supporters have
their tires slashed
their cars lit on fire sucker punched
beaten
unconscious spit on
and no one ever talks about that they
only talk about what happened the
capital which was horrible
but that does not reflect the actuality
of the violence that happened in the
last
four years yeah geraldo you know
speaking of
crime this new democratic congresswoman
freshman congresswoman democrat from
court
from st louis named corey bush she's
defending a riot that was conducted by
115
inmates at a jail with a tweet saying
the right is the language of the unheard
and i want my constituents
in the window their lives and their
rights must be protected my team and i
are working to ensure that the urgent
needs of people
who are incarcerated are defended now
they set
fires in this riot they were very unruly
they
had flooding they were the officers
injured in the riot
and yet we're not hearing about some
resolution on the house floor to
condemn her behavior for justifying what
went on here
well katie just look at the picture over
your right hand shoulder there i mean
these are not
people who are peacefully protesting the
conditions in the jail
conditions in many jails are rotten
don't get me wrong i used to be on the
board
of corrections in new york city and
there's plenty to complain about
but those are rioters those aren't
protesters
uh you know martin luther king's uh
quote the
the the uh right is the language of the
unheard
that's very noble and until you're the
victim of the riot until it's your
property being burned i
i think that this double standard that
democrats have
should be exposed by the president's
lawyers in his impeachment trial
if his words were the incitement that
unleashed that terrible
violence well then what about their
words what about minneapolis and
portland
and seattle and new york city and the
others that burned as a result
i think that the the jailhouse is just a
symbol of what's happened nationwide
uh democrats have uh you know two rules
one for republicans and one for
themselves
yeah and and that might show up in the
impeachment trial tomorrow overall
though it will be covering it in the
afternoon here on the fox
news channel it starts at one o'clock
tomorrow the lead impeachment attorney
bruce castor is planning on rolling a
lot of tape on some of those democrats
words
he told fox news if my eyes look a
little red to the viewers is because
i've been looking at a lot
of video you're likely to hear maxine
water's words played
back right there in that impeachment
hearing as they should be as they should
we will be watching
we'll be